bears Super Bowl champion quarterback
Jim McMahon on the sidelines last night
reunion to the 85 Bears Jim joins us now
good to see you there on the sidelines
you were looking sprite and lively how
you feeling how you doing doing okay
he's doing a lot better than I was
what did it feel like to be out on the
field with those guys last night that
was great to be back in Chicago back
down on that field I'm in the you know
the stadium was we was hopping and
unfortunately they they did get it done
but it was great to see the guys and
just be a part of it what kind of
stories do you tell when you get
together pretty much the same we told
back when we were playing together Oh a
lot of fun a lot of love old memories
and ended up going right after that
pregame I ended up going with Steve
McMichael over to his restaurant bar in
Romeoville for a couple hours and signed
autographs I didn't really see any any
of the game and I was just kind of
bummed to hear that they lost at the end
but you don't watch too much football do
you oh no like I said I didn't see it
hardly any of the game I was I signed
for probably two hours straight at
McMichaels and then I headed back into
the city but did you love football when
you played you just don't like well you
don't love watching football right I
love playing the game I mean it was it
was great to play great to to play with
all those different teams and guys I got
to play with but to watch it no it was
no fun at all how would you do in
today's game I might be able to last a
whole season because they can't hit you
and I would love to throw the ball
around like they did I think they're
doing now because that's what I did in
college so that would have been a lot of
fun do you hold any records from BYU do
you still hold news I have no idea I
would doubt that after you know it's
been what 40-something years and I only
do is throw the ball so I doubt if I
have any left but finally got my name up
on the stadium which was nice Walter
Payton got a statue that was cool yes I
was unfortunately I couldn't make it in
on Tuesday for that but yeah it's great
to see him out there that's for sure
yeah Paulie Jim McMahon still has two
records at BYU most touchdowns in the
season with 53 in 1980
most touchdowns in a game tyrant
mark.wilson eight versus Utah State all
right I'm still yeah there you go
you did something in your career Jim
proud of you yeah I know
could you play differently would you
play differently now then you know the
way you played back then in the 80s
probably not I just I didn't know how to
play any differently I mean I don't know
wasn't wanted to just give up and just
give myself up I was going to make them
earn the tackle and then do you remember
when you just like somebody just leveled
you and you know basically turn out the
lights the worst hit you took well the
worst one I took was probably in college
he knocked me unconscious but when I
still remember the one who's still
giving me problems is the one when I was
in planning against New York in the
playoffs when I was at Minnesota I think
that's when I broke my neck because my
legs went numb twice during that game
and and it's been the problem ever since
who hit you I really don't know I got
hit from one side and then the other so
I don't know who it was so what do you
think of today's game well to me it's
you know I would not want to be a
defensive player for sure I mean those
guys get flagged for for just legal hits
I remember I think it was last year
early in the season play Matthews got
flagged twice and fine twice for four
hits that weren't even you know
malicious and they were just regular
tackles so you know I think it's it's
it's unfortunate the way things are
going but you know I'm out so let them
let them have fun how do you think your
bears defense would do in today's game
they'd get a lot of fines everywhere
because they didn't care they were
putting people out there they didn't
care
health-wise how you doing you know every
day is different I'm still every every
two to three months I have to head back
to New York and see my guy but you know
at least I know like I've told everybody
before I know what's happening with me
so it's and I started having the pains
and I go right back to New York and I'm
okay for a couple months so that's my
that's my schedule did you save anything
from winning the Super Bowl no I wish I
did I had my I had the shoes that I wore
in the game I had those bronze I still
have those but as far as my Jersey the
headbands none of that all of us go did
you ever think or did it ever bother you
that Walter didn't score a Peyton didn't
score a touchdown in the Super Bowl I
know fridge got one in and everybody it
felt like that it you know it bothered
Walter yeah I didn't realize that that
and he never really said anything to me
about it and you know later on but you
know I've talked about this many times I
said you know I think he probably could
have carried the ball hundred times in
that game and I gotten in because that
was their focus I mean they everywhere
he went he was he had six guys chasing
him so you know he carried the ball a
bunch and I think we could have maybe
tried to get him later in the game but
you know we were all out of the game
early in the third quarter and you know
we didn't even realize you know who
scored and who didn't but you know I
don't think it diminishes his legacy at
all I mean the guy was a great football
player and and and we everybody else has
success because of him being on the
field well it's great to talk to you it
was great to see on the sidelines and I
wish you the best health-wise thanks for
calling in alright Dan always a pleasure
guys take care that's Jim McMahon for
more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]